we're back inside the world's most
depressing game and ragout comes in here
I guess I'll let see what the pine is a
could only have a couple stations luck
they say hey hey girl hold it up half a
healthy attack this train is looking at
safe it's probably because it's not but
that's what you got for AG getting as
watch of tickets you know I'm not what
he's like and with all I know
yes craft of balance katha perfect
perfect I can't say in your block event
come on just run it around just running
around because a trip is too long so
what I like and I just talked to some
guys ever
chase last place like our there yet
Oh way there oh we're any other way
I can't alia okay when I say spot-on
about you want some food you better be
nicer and better right now oh you got a
hunger on Chioggia laga hanging out
mm-hmm
scientists scientists yeah yeah yeah we
speak they're right nationally yeah
we're there look at them them nazi
zombies you know
Sally's that not says I also darken this
camera today I can't let's see they
always make it the first bill because no
one in there
yes insisting
all right give it some of that Stephanie
yeah noise I frequency you like that
look at you seeing here bus so a man
looks like this is what man looks like I
know I mess up there and okay
hi all right yeah that's horrible
I know that's a wrap
hello sir
okay I'm gonna check on subsea real
quick so writing wheel I can mess up
perfect come over here you know
I just got an e just going out off this
guy
okay take it both our resources
oh my god
bond was so bad today I mean in this
game I guess
kay puck that out
okay okay okay okay
oh my god
don't ya coming
hey Diane I can't accuse over here what
that's a doctor please it's alright okay
something
okay time to get back out of here
Jesus
Wow this is someone fatter on this way
railway k1 that go to that's above my
back red not be honest eight nine four
four let's get the heck out of here I
don't really have a lot of health for
these guys
print and I'm gonna sure how much more
there has and I can't really tell ya it
so dark on my screen I'm sorry I'm a
much my skin is much lighter than that
guy
I don't do I think I'm like that dark
okay Anna is the mouse out here got good
good
and then I got nothing
so I'm as laying it out
okay I think we have two things now
chances transics so long now that guy
has got that and I did it through hot
but that's okay how much money I go I
wonder if we're going back to here and
we are yeah read somewhere yeah go into
the real factory great
ten it's a house
what I that right
sorry
you know sex is sex
show you sir a lien then so I talked
about that before
sing the arthropods and they can be a
neck get a David second faculties the
urgent
it's a big building great
perfect that's what I'm talking about
you know and I'm saying
great
crap
I sure have a job do unit it was here
dog
you know they say on a leash or
something
you
Wow okay
Jesus
after the hottest gas
Emma imagine tread
okay that's really keep all the nice
chairs I guess I know
skater
now I definitely don't eat them just
would fight all over their hands little
tack packed when I'm moving it's weird
perfect
[Music]
all right I know that is about guys get
out here
nine eight six nine
we're flies there this come to in 17
minutes
fascinating can you send my love is take
a good look at it I'm gonna type at the
are going okay it's fine I'm fine I just
want to laugh and shout bang that's
protects is gonna get jacked up for us
think how many food die how do a food
okay let me see hey need some fat now
now alright prolly
and wait until it's critical yeah
we got one red cats on you like here you
got it today
that's great
it's fine we're happy fine
I cannot rightly learn some snacks or by
purchase now I need a snack or beverage
hey you guys
[Music]
now candidate you know we're like we are
alright nothing here kept seeing me
today
nothing nothing ladies exhale things
that is maybe climb Mountain sir
yeah I guess we're going into that hands
what the heck is that
any zombies here
where
all right so like kill people Jesus
how's that what the heck is this do you
see
this is disgusting a tentacle thing
I'm just trying to get out here
okay hey some food for the people now
I'm checking this real quick redkit
thank God
show a little more sophistication
okay I wasn't necessary break out the
red Keds where I got the Fred let's get
out of here
all right Chinese place you know in a
chance that I don't need all this drama
in a small town like this
hmm any food though
oh this guy's always way out
we come back Oh
Diana
okay I make it
can we check see if they're still alive
got got got got
now we can skip now a baguette
really yeah we're going back to the old
guild beginning
all right a fetishist tonight
commander so this like a military base
all right Guardian nobody knows
Shh s
anything notable here with this
DLF are just Vienna far
dang are those people
what the heck of that but I'm not stop
okay
I don't like this I wish my pistol
so that that's done now the fast one
okay
seven that's six
I was like Timnath lock
that is a critical condition
[Music]
mmm-hmm scram is getting busy
and we got to get going
we're going this way for triple a
manufactory
still get hungry
yeah I understand
I'd like a drop these suckers off place
stocks I step back
and shop this girl on in
all right
what is that oh you got
see people tell now
- I seven bucks
take us that about launch on launch
eight seven why make sure you get a
little stuff I could get get get don't
they'll just get me ahead
oh yeah the green psycho backwards
hmm perplexed really perplexed
this is gigantic just going to have ones
freshman this red thing No thank yous
music ma'am sit here candles
once the guardian
huffing on ROI
can I cook David okay so I'm leaving you
do this half
okay
this place is gigantic I really want to
go pull yet one sec let's check out the
other spot
the hang of this
okay
we take the bloom shoots employer area
green tick see here
mmm-hmm money newspapers nice I get
yeah that's that
cut the green I guess that this is the
beginning okay gotta get back my good ol
friend and all sign there you go baby
then after five
and I guess is banding
laughs is that these guys in there with
us
Gary stole mine now hey stay on this
date sighs checking up on them
how'd I get
what does influence the sign of nothing
about
why it's still saying like love LA
if you look at in
and something stupid shrine step at Chan
and I've got my exercise then Mike idea
you know
all right I'll effect
I was really scared betrayed by herself
at night sick flow through darkness
this is gonna be hard level I can feel
it and I can feel it it is so quiet yeah
I go towards your fan
traitor they don't call us like any more
help of a normal person
I do this
you're shot that I'm just like throw it
okay break this one down and I'll write
that one down pick some things over here
shout out that window
yeah I just hire wrong things around
here
haha
again that's not that again
I have one came is check outs over here
we can't 7i6 down
so this guy is a time because I got
nothing at all for him
so let's do this
hey son that's right yeah yes that all
right guy
how about a house sorry can I help you
with something I like and we like this
all time
what is like okay and maybe si sir
so why a bass I've grown my trend no
it's a Madison
okay great
what that is this best patient crap
trying
how'd it happen here
I say clothing
no that's crazy
okay I guess going on that's s that's
disgusting
10:7 but I'm bot
and okay
whenever any now I don't you
Jesus
no I did that
quiet here man anything going on
right
I walked so far though exhale this is
zombie people I think this would squid
before
hi my name is just canvas this chair
because that's candles
this is a look I said I know I met
- this money
just take the chair what am I sit there
with all funny
what I have a nice night
I'm standing there waiting for my up
there then
stick idea in our work
as I got out of this
either side chat up a table
Oh like a hack
stepping
Oh so begin begin I think
this is once again a game I don't know
okay that's prison
got it
keep a it's always like so wick
okay great
what the heck
hi
that's right
Peter Elliot theft
I hate do anything now why is like his
cell the hallway meant unemployed a
gratis all true did you earned it okay
rap
that here is scared
let's get out of here
it's beautiful down there helpful 10 I
can come out to play
that's better father
hello Jerry what a nice day I'm having
number one that the one didn't make it I
don't
hey guys I live here now
okay fatback's burger
that happen air okay ghost ranch that
guy is the gas has like a badger now I
yes oh it broke hello Kai
just like bracket Thanks
like that like I gotta have it ow
I said I wish I had my train is this not
great should I eat somebody my crepes
should not honey and somebody McDonald's
like rips
and what's going to known here he helped
grow some mushing so Stan but I think I
met the finalization at the chamber done
so I have to go back okay it's my gun
here
I like that paper and I look at you have
those
[Music]
hmm I like if I came up with the cameras
like of the people still obviously there
Brice Taylor stuff so pace well here
hope I get to me down there's a similar
discuss things terrible this guy's house
set the heck
what's going on is I'm going to make it
then
so much money and nothing firm and it is
in a cat - cat over there
Suhani
yes stupid animal
grass they haven't kind of sluggishly
now at can you get outside right
the astronaut charge has been nice pace
out brah
Wow really really good ending actually
and I always hope y'all enjoy thank you
for watching and take care your chains